BRAD MEADER: My name is Brad.
I'm the product lead for
Google endpoint management.
I'm part of the Cloud Identity
product, so part of the Cloud
Identity team.
I'm going to try to keep it
high energy and keep you awake,
here, for a little bit.
I'm going to try not
to talk too much.
We have some demos that
we're going to show you.
So I going to bring up
some of my colleagues
that are listed here
in a little bit.
But first I want to
set a little context
before we get into those demos.
So I'll talk a little bit about
Cloud Identity in general.
So, the idea here is that--
with the proliferation
of mobile devices,
and the movement of enterprise
access to the cloud--
it's kind of changed the
way that employees work.
All of us expect the same
kind of consumer-grade access
from our enterprise
applications.
And it's actually
putting a burden on IT
to support this, right?
So the workplace is
undergoing a transformation
to support this expectation.
IT decision makers
are at the forefront
of creating a secure,
connected, and collaborative
workplace where identity,
access, and device management
is front and center
of all of that.
So, network security
was different
when I started my career,
and so was collaboration.
And I think those two are
kind of tied, hand-in-hand,
together.
As long as we stayed on the
network, we stayed secure.
This tied us to our desks
and it hindered the way
we could work with others.
And so, in a way, that the IT
security model kind of dictated
the way that we could
work with our partners,
and our vendors,
and our customers.
And so now that that
perimeter is gone,
and we've got this dynamic
security posture tied
to users and devices
and applications,
the result is a
better way to work
that allows us to easily
collaborate across
different applications,
from different places,
on different devices.
Google pioneered this concept--
we call it BeyondCorp--
in 2011.
We've been working on
this for eight years now.
The intent has been to
enable every employee
to work from untrusted
networks without the use
of a traditional VPN.
We've been perfecting
this internally
for these eight years--
shifting all of
our access controls
from the network to
individual users and devices--
allowing them to
work from anywhere.
And so, what we've done,
is we've taken that,
and we package it up, and we've
started selling that as part
of our Cloud Identity product.
Now, the Cloud Identity
product was officially
launched in March of last
year, so it's about a year old.
But it's not actually
a new product.
It's something that we
had baked in as part
of G Suite for years.
But we finally thought, oh,
this is something that--
even if you're not making
the move to the productivity
suite--
we think our customers
could benefit from.
So, that's kind of the
overview of Cloud Identity.
So what does device management
have to do with that?
That's what I'm here to
talk about in more depth.
So, first, let me
talk a little bit
about what I think device
management is, or endpoint
management.
So, a primer, right?
So I think of it
in three pillars.
So I think of device
management itself,
where you're locking
down a device.
So you get an inventory
of every device
that access is your data.
You enforce policies
on that device
before they are allowed access,
so you might enforce a passcode
on a device.
You want to have the ability
to take action on that device,
if something happens, if the
data becomes the device becomes
lost or stolen.
So, basically, locking
down a device before you
allow access to
sensitive information.
The second pillar is
application management.
So, once you've got a device
and it's locked down in a way
that you feel like
it's secure, you
want to make sure that your
users are productive on that.
And so you want to make
sure that they have access
to the right
applications and they're
configured in the right way.
And so things like
application whitelisting,
applications that separate
out work and personal data,
distributing applications
and configuring them--
that sort of thing-- that's
the second pillar of what
I consider enterprise
endpoint management.
And then the third piece
is general administration
of your fleet of devices.
So you've got these
devices out there.
You want to audit
and report on them.
You want to be able to maintain
threat mitigation, protocol
on that.
And just general
enterprise management
of your device fleet.
So why is all of this important?
So more than one quarter
of smartphone owners
do not use a screen lock.
So this is a couple
of years old here.
When you dig into
that data, that's
not limited to consumers.
So that means that a quarter
of all folks carrying
a modern smartphone
have figured out
how to turn off screen
lock on their device.
I don't know if you've set
up a smartphone recently,
it's hard to do.
So you've made the
decision that, I
don't want to be bothered with
a device lock on my device.
And I would just want it to be
open for the world to get into.
And then depending on the
data that you look at,
only about one in
10, or maybe 15%,
of devices used for business
use are under device management.
If they're not under
device management,
then you don't know if
you've enforced a screen
lock on that device or not.
So, this is what I'm
here to say, right?
If you're an
administrator and you're
allowing enterprise access to
your data on a mobile device,
and you don't have
device management turned
on that device,
then your employees
can leave their
device at a Starbucks.
And it could potentially
be completely open.
Somebody can pick
up that device,
and they can get complete access
to whatever sensitive data
resides in the device.
Not only is that bad for the
potential loss of your data,
you could run afoul of
security regulations as well.
So I think that is bad,
and so I'm on a mission
to try to fix that.
So, why do I think that is?
So, the reality is, it's been
difficult to setup device
management.
You send people
through a lot of hoops.
There are a lot of privacy
concerns to set it up.
And so, in general,
people don't want
to deal with the headaches of
implementing device management.
And so, at Google,
where we're on a mission
to try to fix that.
We're on a mission
to try to figure out
how to make device management
as easy as possible,
as seamless as possible, so
that as an administrator,
you don't have a
problem turning it on.
And as an end user,
you don't have
a problem having device
management on your device.
So our mission is to
maximize user productivity
while keeping data secure.
These two things
are diametrically
opposed to each
other, all right?
So it's really easy to
keep your data secure.
You lock it down, you don't give
anybody access, done, right?
It's really easy to
keep people productive.
They can get access to your
data anytime, anywhere.
You just open it wide
for access anywhere,
but then it's not secure.
So we're constantly
looking at what
is the right balance
between those two things.
I think we've achieved a pretty
good balance between those two.
At Google-- our
endpoint management--
we manage more than 55
million 30 day active devices.
That includes Chrome
OS, Android, iOS,
and some other devices.
We've managed to
grow pretty rapidly
over the last few years.
And we've done that
by making simple,
easy to use device management.
And those are the demos that I'm
going to show you a little bit
later, I want to show
you how we've done that.
In many places, we've turned on
device management by default.
So that we've got basically--
even for administrators
who don't know they
need device management--
we've got their back.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit more in three areas
around device management.
And I'm going to give a demo
in each one of these areas.
So, hopefully, we'll be
ready to go on these.
So, first, let's talk about
comprehensive protection.
So, on the mobile side,
we manage iOS and Android.
We manage company-owned devices,
we manage personal devices.
We also help secure the desktop
through the use of an Endpoint
Verification Chrome extension.
That's something that
we launched last year
and talked about it
at Next last year.
We curate and
install G Suite apps.
We're going to talk a
little bit more about that
and show a demo a
little bit later.
And we, also, are big fans
of Android Enterprise.
And we support Android work
profiles to allow selected data
control, where you can
completely separate out
your work and your
personal data on a device,
so that you don't
bleed between the two.
Today, we are launching
a new feature.
It's Drive File
Stream management.
So, if you're not familiar
with Drive File Stream,
it's the world's
largest hard drive.
So, Drive File Stream allows
you to link up your Cloud drive
to your Windows or
your Mac machine.
It looks just like a regular
hard drive on your device.
It automatically syncs
in the background
the files that you need.
The first thing that you
hear from administrators
is, we love this
feature but we want
to make sure that
we have control over
that if the device
becomes lost or stolen.
We want to make sure that we
can take care of that device.
So, today, we are launching
management of that device.
We can limit Drive
File Stream access
to only company-owned devices.
And should that device
become lost or stolen,
we can wipe that device
and/or block that device.
And to show you--
thanks-- and to show you
a demo of that today,
I'm going to pass it over
to my colleague Sachin.
Sachin.
SACHIN PARSEWAR: Can
we switch to the demo?
Cool.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Sachin.
I will [? be allowed ?]
two personas today.
One is a device
administrator with the cap,
and one the CEO of the company.
The company name
is Technizza.com,
we deliver pizzazz
at lightning speed.
So I'm an admin console,
admin at Google.com.
In apps, G Suite, drive
and dock settings.
I'm inside Drive File Stream.
I have allowed Drive File
Stream in my organization.
With this, as Brad
told, admin will
be able to inventory all the
devices which are accessing
drive files offline.
I will also be able to
block and wipe the devices.
I have also the capability to
allow Drive File Stream only
on authorized devices,
like company-owned devices.
But today I will do a demo
without enabling the same.
So let's switch the
persona and I'm here,
I'm the CEO of the company--
Technizza.com-- we deliver
pizzazz at lightning speed.
So I have a flight and
I want to work offline.
So, just now, I have
installed Drive File Stream
in my organization,
in this laptop.
So let's log in for the
first time from this machine,
Sachinp@technizza.com.
Let me put my magic password.
And as you can see,
the [? very ?] files
have started to load up.
So, let me open
Drive file folder.
And as you can see,
I have this, like,
presentation which I need
to give it to my investors
at the presentation.
So let me make some of these
files available offline.
So I have a demo, as well.
Let me make it offline so that
I can do some updates over here.
So I'm going on the
flight and let's go back
to the domain administrator.
Let me wear my cap.
Cool, so, just now,
my CEO called me
and said that he has lost his
Mac machine in the airport.
And he's CEO so he has a lot
of confidential information.
Let me go and see if
there exists a device.
Boom, we have our one
device with Sachin name.
Let me go deep dive
into the machine.
So as you can see, I can
see the serial number
of the machine, operating
system of the OS, which is Mac--
this is the Mac machine.
How much is the cache size?
I just now downloaded
more than 100 MB.
What is the Drive
File Stream version?
When it was it first synced,
when it was last synced?
On the left side, I
can take actions--
like block the device--
so that whatever
data is present,
it will be removed
from that device.
And no further access will
be allowed from that device.
I can wipe the account one
time, so that one time,
data is removed from the device.
I can delete the device, or I
can remove all the information
of the device so that what's
happening on the device
is visible, very easy.
So, as you can see, let
me block the device.
You can see on the
right side what happens.
So let me block it.
And one device is blocked.
Boom, all the data from
the device is gone.
Administrator has
blocked this device--
from this computer-- so that
I can no longer access it
and the device data is gone.
As Brad mentioned, we
are launching this today.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD MEADER: Thank you, Sachin.
Let's go back to the slides.
I love that, sweet.
Sweet when a demo
pulls off like that.
Great, so, next one.
Let's talk about
easy management,
and then we'll come back up
for another quick demo, here.
So I talked a little bit
about our growth and device
management.
So one of the things that
we've been focused on
is what is the end
user experience
for device management.
I think that a lot
of people hesitate
to turn on management because
people have to jump through too
many hoops, you know?
They don't want a ton of calls
to their help center on how
to set up and get access
to Gmail, and Drive,
and Calendar and
that sort of thing.
So, what we implemented was
agentless basic management
for all of our G Suite and
Cloud Identity customers.
What that gets them is an
inventory of all the devices
that access their accounts.
It allows them to enforce a
passcode on those devices,
and it allows them
to selectively wipe
the accounts on those devices.
And it's important to
note that it allows
them to wipe the
accounts on the devices,
but not the devices themselves.
So it means that the
administrator has control
over the corporate
data on the device,
but they're not going to be
able to wipe somebody's baby
pictures off of that device.
We can do this without
installing an agent
on the device.
Just the act of, say,
logging into Gmail
enables this device management.
We turned this on by default
for all of our new G Suite
customers about a year ago.
And we've been
slowly retroactively
applying it to all of our
existing G Suite customers.
We haven't finished
that rollout yet,
but we're in the
process of doing that.
So it's a very easy
way to get management
of every single device--
every single mobile device--
that touches G Suite and
Cloud Identity accounts.
We're really pleased with this
because what this means is--
even the administrators
who haven't figured out yet
that device management is
very important to them--
the first time that someone
leaves their mobile device
that's filled with health care
data or social security numbers
in a Starbucks unprotected,
we've got their back.
They can go and they can wipe
the account off that device.
So, very pleased with that.
For those enterprises that
need more bells and whistles
and more policy
enforcement, we do
provide more advanced controls.
In that case, it's
not agentless,
you have to install a
Device Policy controller
on the device.
But we do work very hard to
make that as easy as possible.
And so, you know,
what I like to say
is that, you're all here
today at Google Cloud Next
to talk to us about
enterprise software.
You may be aware that Google
also has some consumer brands
that we work on, as well.
So what we do is, we
take some of the lessons
that we've learned from
providing great consumer
experiences to
billions of users.
And we try to apply that to
enterprise software, as well.
And so, even in the places where
we might require our end users
to jump through
a few extra hoops
to get more advanced
management on their devices,
we really focus on the
end user experience
and try to make that as
seamless as possible so
that the administrator
doesn't get burdened
with a lot of support
calls, and the end user
knows exactly what is
happening on that device.
We're completely
transparent about the rights
that the administrator
has on that device.
And, ultimately, they end
up installing, and getting
on their way, and
being productive
in whatever they need to do with
that enterprise information.
And then, finally, we also
spend some time thinking
about how do we make
the admin's life easier.
And so one of the
things we've implemented
are customizable rules
on the admin side,
so you can implement--
or automate-- everyday tasks
on the administrator side.
So things like, oh, I want to
lock down a device if someone
tries to log in
with the passcode,
you know, incorrectly
five times in a row.
I might automatically trigger
an account wipe on that device
to protect data on that device.
So, today, I want to show
you-- we actually launched this
a couple of months ago--
but we've extended the agentless
management concept on Android
to include application
management.
So in addition to
inventorying the device,
being able to enforce a
passcode on the device,
and being able to wipe the
account on the device--
we also, on Android, can
whitelist applications.
And push those applications
to Android devices
without the need to
install a Device Policy
controller on the device.
And so, once again,
we're going to have
Sachin show us a demo of that.
Can we switch to
the demo, please?
Yeah, that's right.
Excuse me, can we switch
over to the computer, please?
There we go, thanks.
SACHIN PARSEWAR: Cool.
Hi, again.
My name is Sachin and
again, I have two personas,
one with an administrator with
cap, and one CEO without cap.
So, I'm in admin console,
admin.google.com.
I am admin of Technizza.com,
we deliver pizzazz
at lightning speed.
I'm in device management setup.
And what you can see
is device management
is enabled in the basic mode.
As Brad mentioned, admin will
be able to enforce screen lock
on the device, will be able to
remove account from the device,
and we will be able to do
application management.
So, let me go to the
application management
inside Admin Console, Device
Management, App Management.
And here I am in the
Android App Management.
You can restrict
app availability
to whitelisted apps, only.
But to do that, you need
advanced device management,
which is, of course,
part of G Suite itself.
But today I'm going to talk
about mainly basic device
management.
You can do whitelist
applications
as well as make applications
install silently
in the background.
So let me manage
these applications.
So far, now, I have
whitelisted around 13 apps.
So, let me go to the
Lookout app and make
it installed automatically.
Let me edit the configuration.
And as you can see, I can
automatically install app
on all these devices.
So the rest of the
settings will be
applicable for the
advanced device management.
So let me switch the persona
and go back to my device.
Cool.
Hi, everyone.
I am CEO of the company.
Last time I lost my
laptop, so I'm logging in
from my mobile phone.
So, here, you can see there
is only one account, which
is my personal account.
Let me add my corporate
account, which is Technizza.com.
So let me add it.
As you can see, I have very
secret password on the device.
Let me put
Sachinp@technizza.com.
Let me put my magic password.
Let me agree to the
terms of conditions.
And as you can see,
all of my information,
which I need to talk about like
the presentation, and so on,
the marks, the app,
and all the information
is present so that I can
talk to the investors.
Let me go to the
Play Store and let
me find out what all
apps are recommended
by my administrator.
As you can see in background,
automatically, Lookout app
has started to download,
because I had done
that setting in background.
So let me go to technizza.com.
And as you can
see, there is home.
This is the new tab which I
added, which is work apps.
So all the recommended
apps, which
are done by administrator,
are visible.
This is without Device
Policy App or controller
being on the device.
Let me switch the persona, let
me go to the administrator.
What happened?
BRAD MEADER: Uh-oh.
We out of power up here?
Let's see, did we hit a snag?
These monitors are out, too.
SACHIN PARSEWAR: Yeah.
BRAD MEADER: There we go.
All right, temporary glitch.
SACHIN PARSEWAR: So, just now,
again, Sachin called me back
and the CEO called me back.
And again, he lost his
mobile device as well.
So as you can see, I go to
Device Management devices
and I see one device, here.
Let me wipe the account
from the device.
So all the account related
data-- confidential data--
goes away from that device.
So let me pull the screen so
that you can see on right side,
also, what happens.
So, let me wipe the account.
The account is wiping.
Boom, the account is gone.
So you can see it from even
Gmail app, there is no account,
there's no
technizza.com account.
And even in Play
Store, it is gone.
What we also have done latest is
we are showing one notification
to the end user, so
that they can uninstall
all apps which are
installed or associated
with that particular account.
So let me click on this.
And as you can see, there is
a Lookout app, Salesforce app.
These apps had installed
[INAUDIBLE] technizza.com.
I can go and delete it.
And then, with this
deletion, all the data
associated with those
apps is also going away.
So, we are making
it safe and secure.
Thanks, thanks, Brad.
BRAD MEADER: Great,
thank you, Sachin.
[APPLAUSE]
So, it's easy,
agentless management.
You know, we're really
happy with this.
And it's something we did in
conjunction with the Android
team.
All right, let's talk
about Enterprise Ready.
And this one's a little
bit more in-depth,
and we've got an exciting
demo we want to show you
on this one, as well.
And then we're going
to, eventually,
get into some questions.
If you have some questions,
you can submit them
on the Dory, which is
linked in the description
on the Next app, or we're going
to have some mics up here.
So stick around for that.
So, we're getting into
the homestretch, here.
So on the Enterprise
site-- so, we've
talked about easy management.
We're very focused on that.
That's not to say that we don't
want to support the Enterprise
use case.
We are enterprise ready.
For those folks who want
bullet proof management,
we're here for you.
So we do provide all
the bells and whistles
you would expect-- advanced
audio capabilities--
to get reports about users
and devices in OS versions.
We showed a little bit of
the easy app management.
We provide more
advanced app management
for both iOS and Android.
When you want to install a
Device Policy controller, that
includes, on Android,
the ability to create,
manage configurations that you
can push out to your devices,
as well.
We provide proactive
security recommendations
for device management with our
Security Center integration.
And, just recently,
Android Enterprise
launched the Android Enterprise
Recommended program for EMMs.
This is in this
past January and we
were one of the launch
partners for that.
One of the features
that we're talking about
is-- it's not quite launched
yet, but it's coming soon.
So, I mentioned earlier, we're
fans of Android Enterprise
and the Android work
profile-- the ability
to completely separate out work
and personal data on an Android
phone.
I say that not
just because we're
Google and Android's
Google, although maybe.
But also because they've really
thought through the enterprise
use case.
And it's really easy, as an EMM,
for us to kind of flip a switch
and separate out work and
personal data on a device.
It's not quite as easy
to do that on iOS.
But we recognize that
a lot of our customers
have a need to provide
enterprise support on iOS.
And so one of the features that
we will be launching soon--
and we have in testing now--
is the data
exfiltration protection
for iOS, which does things
like restrict copy/paste
between corporate and personal
accounts on an iOS device.
So watch for more announcements
to come on this in the coming
months, throughout the year.
I want to talk a little
bit about something
you should hear a lot about
throughout this conference,
context-aware access.
So, kind of, traditional
mobile management
and traditional device
management has, in the past,
been a very binary thing, right?
Which is, you put a
Device Policy controller
into the device, it
makes sure that policies
are enforced on that device.
And it's either compliant
or not compliant,
and then you allow access.
And that model is not
going to continue to work,
because there are many
different signals that you need
to look at on a device to
determine whether you should
allow access.
And those signals
change over time,
because they change
depending on the user that's
logged into the device.
They change depending
on the applications that
are being used on the device.
They change depending on
the environmental variables,
like what network the device is
on, what country the device is
located on, et cetera.
And context-aware
access is something
that we were working on to
support those types of security
scenarios.
There's more to come
in other sessions
and I'm going to
have a slide, here,
that will show you some of the
sessions you should go watch
to see about that.
So what we are launching
in beta is the ability
to take this BeyondCorp
Devices API--
will allow us to integrate
with third parties
to ingest additional
signals from other companies
to supplement that context-aware
access rules engine.
So what we look at is,
we work with partners,
partners send us
data, on oh, here
are the types of apps
that we see installed
on the device that
might be malicious,
or other things, other
environmental variables.
And we put those into
our rules engine,
and an administrator
can make a decision on
whether they want
to grant access
to corporate data on
those devices or not.
And so what we want to do is,
rather than tell you about it,
we wanted to bring up a
partner to talk about it.
So Sneha, from Lookout, is
going to come up and tell you
a little bit about
integration that we've
built with Lookout for this.
SNEHA SACHIDANANDA: Thanks
for having me, Brad.
So, hi, everyone.
My name is Sneha
Sachidananda, I'm
a senior product
manager at Lookout.
So I want to give
you some context.
As we all know, today, employees
are working from everywhere.
We are working from
coffee shops, airports,
movie theaters.
And we are always accessing
our corporate data like email,
our Docs, Slides, et
cetera on mobile devices.
So that poses a
pretty big challenges
for enterprises
who have completely
embraced mobile devices
throughout their workplace.
So, how can they ensure
that corporate data which
is being accessed
from these devices
are actually happening
in a secure fashion?
And also, at the
same time, they have
to balance the user privacy,
as well as not disrupt
the user experience.
So, today, I'm here
to talk about how
we are going to do that with
Lookout and Google Cloud
Identity.
Next slide.
So for those of you who have
not heard about Lookout--
Lookout Mobile
Endpoint Security,
we help enterprises
protect corporate data
by preventing any kind of
threats that can happen
on employee mobile devices.
We have been doing
this over a decade,
and we have protected over
more than 100 million devices
across 150 countries.
And for enterprises,
we actually protect
across a spectrum of risks.
And on a broad range, we divide
them into four categories.
So, the first category that we
have is called app-based risks.
So, an example of
this can be a malware
that can be either downloaded
from Play Store or even side
loaded on an employee device.
An example of zero-day
malware that Lookout detected
is a Pegasus, iOS spyware.
Some of you may have
heard of that one.
And we have device-based risk.
So an example of this
can be when a device
could get rooted or jailbroken.
We are shortly going to
show you a demo of that.
And then we have
network-based risk,
where you could connect
to an unsafe Wi-Fi.
There could be-- a
man-in-the-middle attack is
an example of that.
And finally, phishing attack
can happen when an employee
could click on an email--
a malicious email-- which could
be either as a text message,
or even on a social media
platform like WhatsApp.
So what we do is
when anytime there
is a risk detected on any
of these four categories,
we provide protection
for corporate data
through what we call it as
continuous conditional access.
Next slide.
So for this integration with
the Lookout and Google Cloud
Identity, what we
have done is we
have integrated our device
held data with the BeyondCorp
Devices API.
So when an end user is trying
to access a corporate resource--
like, let's say G Suite--
on their mobile device,
in real time we
will give context
about the health of the device.
So once we get to know what
the context of the device
is, then you can apply all
of these rules engines,
as well as you can apply
different enforcement
policy as an admin, to make
sure that only safe devices get
access to the
corporate resources.
So without giving
too much away, I
would like to invite
Atul Tulshibagwale
Google, who will actually show
a demo of this integration.
ATUL TULSHIBAGWALE:
Hi, everyone.
Thanks, Sneha.
So, I'm going to show you a
demo today of the Devices API
and how a third
party, like Lookout,
can use the Devices
API to enforce
greater security on the devices
that are managed by Google.
Oh, yes.
So, here, I have a
device that there
is no agent on this device.
This is just a simple
device on which
I have my personal account.
I'm calling myself Harry
Potter and I'm going
to add my work account, here.
And I've just started a
new job at this company
called Terragon.
And I'm logging
into the device, I'm
adding my corporate
account now which
is harrypotter@terragon.tv.
I need to enter my
password, of course.
So that's my password
and oh, do they actually
show it to everyone?
Sorry.
I'm here, I'm in.
I see my work email here.
And my boss has just sent
me this new document.
Oh, OK, well, I thought there
was an interesting email
in my personal account.
But before I go there, I'm
told to activate the Lookout
application.
So I'm going to
activate it here.
So activate, enter my
work email address.
And what Lookout
is now doing is,
it's basically
scanning my device.
I need to give it the permission
so that it can do its job.
You know, it's
scanning my device,
it's making sure that
everything is OK with my device,
and it's analyzing things.
Now, in the meantime, I can show
you on the Google Admin console
that the device has been
registered and approved
without an agent.
And on the Lookout
console, here, you'll
be able to see that the device
is connected and secured.
And so, if you go back
to the device screen,
you see that Lookout
found no issues here.
So, what I'm going to
do now, is I'm going
to go to my personal email.
Oh, there's a application
for the university
I was wanting to apply to.
So, I'm going to
click on this link
so that I get that application.
And it's giving me some language
that I don't really understand.
So I'm just going to
click on that link
and it's going to
download this file.
I don't know what
that file is, but it
looks like if I download it,
I get into the university.
So, I'm going to do that.
And, you know, behold, this
is Lookout basically getting
triggered and saying that
the device is now, you know,
this file is harmful.
And I should not basically,
do anything with it.
I'm going to close it.
But just because the file was
downloaded on this device,
now you will see that,
in the Gmail client,
the work account
has been eliminated.
So if I had downloaded
any files or anything,
all those would be gone.
And how this happened,
actually, is because--
on the Google Admin
console, the administrator
had configured a rule.
Now, this is under Google
Admin, you see a Rules tab.
And within that
there is a rule here,
that if a partner
signals, you know,
that there is a high
risk on the device, then
you should wipe the corporate
account from that device.
And so if the basic integrity
sees that there's a high risk,
we should wipe the corporate
account on that device.
And that's the rule.
And if you look
at the audit logs,
you will see that the latest
audit logs will show--
this is at 1:20 PM--
that the risk was changed
from none to high,
and then the account wipe was
pending, and then executed.
So this happened without
the user actually
having to do anything.
And this shows how
we can collaborate
with other partners.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD MEADER: Great,
thank you, Atul.
OK, homestretch.
One thing I want to mention.
We were named a 2018 Gartner
Peer Insights Customers
Choice for Enterprise
Mobility Management Suites.
That was probably
about nine months ago.
I'm particularly proud of this.
We're not in the Gartner
Magic Quadrant at the moment,
but our customers went and
nominated us for this award.
They said things like,
we like Google EMM
because it's simple
and easy to use.
And those are the things
that we're trying to do.
So, that makes me very happy.
Hopefully, you take away
one thing from this talk.
I think device management
is very important.
I'm pretty biased
about that because I'm
the product lead for device
management at Google.
But I think if you're allowing
access to your enterprise data
out in the wild, you really
need to make sure that you've
locked that down in some way.
So you can get device
management anywhere.
It doesn't have to be with us.
What I want to
make sure you know
is it doesn't have
to be difficult.
So if you already are a G Suite
user, if you're already a G
Suite customer, if you're
already a Cloud Identity
customer, you can get it
from us at no extra charge.
So, you know, you don't
have to get it from us,
but get it somewhere.
That's what I'm trying to say.
So, if you'd like to learn
more about what we're doing,
you can go to
cloud.google.com/identity.
And if you're
interested, specifically,
in the BeyondCorp
APIs that we showed--
if you're interested
in being a partner,
or if you're interested in
beta testing as a customer--
send us an email
at beyondcorpallian
ce.alliance@google.com.
And we'll put you in the
queue for the sign up list.
Make sure everybody has time
to take a picture of that
before I switch
to the next slide.
One other thing I
want to show you--
get your cameras
ready for this--
we've got sessions, here,
throughout the week.
This is one of the
first sessions.
Here are some other
sessions that I think
you might be interested in.
The partner sessions--
the ones marked
PAR-- are limited to
partner track, only.
So if you've got a P on
your tag, you can go.
But I would encourage you to
go and check some of these out,
we've got a lot of
exciting things coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]